on the morning of the 6th of May their
majesties will travel from Buckingham
Palace in the king's procession to
Westminster Abbey in the Diamond Jubilee
estate coach the procession accompanied
by the sovereign's escort of the
household Cavalry will leave Buckingham
Palace through the center gate and
proceed down the mall passing through
admiralty Arch and along the south side
of Trafalgar Square it will continue
down Whitehall and along Parliament
street the king's procession will then
travel around the east and south sides
of parliament Square to Broad Sanctuary
to arrive at the sanctuary of
Westminster Abbey where the coronation
service is going to start 11 in the
morning now after the ceremony their
majesties will travel in the gold State
coach from Westminster Abbey to
Buckingham Palace the coronation
procession will be much larger in scale
taking the same route in Reverse Skies
Sabbath Chowdhury has more details for
us from the Royal Muse at Buckingham
Palace
in public but there when it matters and
now making a comeback
this gold State coach is the symbol of
all major Royal events it's been used
for centuries and next month it will
transport the king and the queen from
the ceremony at Westminster Abbey to
here in Buckingham Palace this is the
heights of pageantry
[Music]
despite not being real gold The Carriage
weighs four tons it's only for the
Monarch's use and was used just four
times during the lake Queen's reign
but in a break from tradition the king
and queen consoles ride to the ceremony
will look a little different
the Diamond State coach is the newest
State coach in the Royal Muse in London
it was built for Queen Elizabeth II and
Prince Philip and first used by them for
the state opening of parliament in 2014.
it's got some incredibly exciting
features including the crown at the top
carved from a piece of HMS Victory and
inside that there can be hidden a camera
to record processions a very modern
Innovation but keeping with tradition
the king will wear the Saint Edwards
Crown the only time it's worn by the
Monarch with less than four weeks to go
the pressure at Buckingham Palace is on
if you're a little bit nervous or
anxious it would pass down to the horses
so we all very much get onto job mode
and and make sure that we get there
safely and the horse is literally
respond to your age so you've got to be
the the calm bold one to say it's okay
Lads we can do this and that's also been
colleague Martin's Family motto for the
past four generations my
great-grandfather start started here in
1914 and he was here for Jules the sixth
coronation we have obviously done this
for for years and for the last what six
or seven times the vehicle's gone out
one member of my family has been part of
it it's a job as far as we're concerned
it just happened that we're
we do it and we're part of the royal
family traditions both new and old ready
to welcome the king come Coronation Day
Saba Chowdhury Sky News